Kiki Palmer's boyfriend went from like
guy no one was really paying that much
attention to to the internet's Public
Enemy Number One overnight and that's
because and you may already know this
because it felt like all the algorithms
on social media were like we're gonna
force feed you this information he
appeared to not be happy with and shamed
Kiki over an outfit that she wore and if
you don't know his name is Darius
Jackson he and Kiki actually welcomed
the first kid together in February and
Kiki recently was just having a fun
night out attending Usher's residency in
Las Vegas with video showing ushers
serenading her up close and Darius uh
seemingly not a huge fan of this with
him specifically taking issue with the
bodysuit and sheer dress that she had on
with him writing on Twitter it's the
outfit though you a mom and immediately
people jumped on this man saying don't
date a baddie if you're gonna be this
insecure you're an embarrassment
accusing him of trying to police a
woman's choices also saying with her
being a new mom you should be trying to
be supportive lift her confidence up but
Darius uh did not Sway in the face of
backlash instead doubling down in a post
writing we live in a generation where a
man of the family doesn't want the wife
and mother to his kids to Showcase booty
cheeks to please others and he gets told
how much of a hater he is this is my
family in my representation I have
standards and morals to what I believe I
rest my case
then keep it within your family and then
uh don't expose that [__] on social
media
if you want to have a conversation with
that's my wife then keep it safe to your
wife
why do you have to say to the world and
your wife
so I recently like cardi B and uh and
her boyfriend had a beef and
how are they responding to each other
online
y'all don't have each other's phone
number what's what the [__] is going on
like I don't get it it's like if we we
push this little thing sometimes it's
one thing that I find really cringe and
people do and it's fun if you do it I
think it's cringe is when you post on
social media
I wanna wish happy birthday to a special
person in my life
my husband
weren't you in the bed this morning with
the [__] couldn't you say happy
birthday to him couldn't you be like hey
happy birthday and then move on with
your life no you gotta say to everybody
this not you're not saying happy
birthday this is a flex that you have a
boyfriend and your other lonely [__]
don't and also my boyfriend hey hey it's
just like whenever you say it let's Push
It Forward R.I.P to my grandma your
grandma don't have internet up there
she did okay
she not gonna see it and she just have
to expose that you feel bad and I
understand it that's some coping
mechanism of some people and I get that
I still think it's corny
all right you do your [__] dead
he not gonna see it I would like to wish
a special happy birthday to my
three-year-old your three-year-old
toddler don't read
now that's one thing but if you push it
forward if you have something to say to
the person say it to the person now
you're creating a whole ass drama if
people are talking [__] let them talk
let them talk it's like if I'm using
this camera to talk to my wife that's
weird
sometimes you people in like the public
eye or mad corny and mad weird that's
weird you got it that's my wife no
you're exposed it to the world that you
were not happy with it then the world
gonna answer
I also understand why celebrities say
they're in a monogamous relationship and
it feels like the social media is always
third Wheeling yes it's like I take you
to be my lovely wedded wife and like
[__] who you talking to Twitter or your
wife I don't know
I don't know what y'all do I'm not even
gonna I'm not even gonna talk about the
standards I'm not gonna talk about this
I don't care about this I'm like why is
he posting that [__] on Twitter why did
you just text her you had an issue with
it I think there's nothing wrong with
having an issue with that outfit I think
there's nothing wrong with having an
issue with her going on with Usher and
you know getting started I I perfectly
understand why some people feel uneasy
about it that's not my problem well
that's something you discuss between
each other and on top of that you have
to understand that at that level uh it's
more accessible if it's a fan fan it's
one thing it's someone that whatever
anyways all that to say I don't care
about all that that's your problem but
you cannot use you cannot use you cannot
use the term and the phrase It's my
family I do what I want but before you
expose it to the world the world's gonna
answer okay we are investing you can't
talk about all people mind your business
but every time you end you you expose
your drama no we invested okay we on we
on we on season three episode seven of
your life so even if I did Grant you
okay the posting it on social media is
an acceptable way to talk to your
partner let's say I'm saying you know
what this is normal how is it productive
to the relationship
you ever beef with somebody
you ever try to handle that beef in
front of millions of people yo good luck
everybody's gonna chime in without even
having information anybody who wants
conflict resolution knows if you got an
issue with someone in your group of
friends you pull them aside privately
and you have a discussion peacefully
having that discussion in front of
everybody else when everyone else is
chiming in and Pride's in the way and
you don't want like a [__] in front of
other people you're not going to find a
resolution conflict so all I'm seeing
with this [__] is a bunch of nonsense
but the dude's going to be taking most
of the else because he look like a [__]
in front of everybody
this is what it ends up looking like now
as far as her having her ass she's
hanging out that depends on the
relationship some guys are cool with
that some not that's something y'all got
to negotiate between each other but
people trying to say oh men who feel
like that are insecure whatever it's
like no some people don't want a partner
who are out there looking trashy who
walking around in a see-through Tong or
whatever sorry that's just gonna be the
reality okay so it's perfectly
acceptable for some people not be okay
with it but that's something you discuss
with your partner and you figure out
with your partner not with me not with
preach not with the internet not with
anybody else So for anybody watching so
let at least celebrities make money off
they [__] drama online and some of
you [__] poor people just doing it
for free just because you a little
dysfunctional needs something at least I
said oh I understand why cardi B and her
husband do it because they're drama
farmers and that keeps them in the
Limelight because their music been trash
but sometimes I post something too in a
story like a meme or something
like is that about me it's like
hello
if I got a problem with you why would I
be post Nation online you just be
looking for [__] if you're if if the
shoe fits where [__] but I'm not
thinking about nobody when I post my
[__] I post my [__] because I think it's
funny it's memes carry on but y'all
[__] do have some agendas
sometimes
that's your corn so yeah that's my
thoughts on this whole thing I do I
don't want to spend because I really
don't care about celebrity stuff but
just seeing people post their [__]
online is just weird to me but there's
anything else nah all right let's know